[Music]
i know who killed the kids off
[Music]
i would love a bottle of water
that's the one
i'm sure you won't talk this out no
particularly not
okay
[Music]
[Music]
he's on this train oh that narrows it
down
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people and someone dies i
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
and he didn't die okay the wedding
tequila
johannesburg
it's time for some change you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
[Music]
we need to find the person who took that
case
that's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia jobs the twins yeah and i'm
so sure they're twins get off the train
[Music]
i missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
oops he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm i'm working on it get off
at the next stop sounds so easy when you
say it one little prick from this you
know what happens yes your blood
congeals i'll give you guys set yes
[ __ ]
you're going to want to hear the whole
story that's waiting for some kiara the
white death with his army of assassins
there's this soulless psychotic leader
with the largest criminal organization
on the planet shoved right inside
i don't see the white death letting any
of us off this train
we need to come up with a plan
[Music]
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma
[Music]
i gotta get off this train
[Music]
sorry buddy
in movie theaters
[Music]
you